citizens of the reject Nation we've changed
the tire because we're here for another James
gun thinking images Guardians of the
Galaxy they've got a full trailer here
for the next installment of phase five after
Ant-Man of the Lost quantumania heads up our
review for quantumania will be going up uh
on Tuesday you know what koi I'm gonna see
it Monday you should uh let's do one for the
channel too we'll do a non-spoiler one I got
you yeah well let's get to you know what
to do make sure you go ahead leave a like
koi undoubtedly will be the experts in this
video for sure so let's see what's going on
foreign
love
that girl died but then she came back came back a
totaled dick oh please he left out some important
information but that is the gist of it oh
I love these movies let's play a Name Game
I'll wait
my sacred mission is to create the perfect Society
yes evolutionary he didn't want to make things
perfect oh just hated things the way they are
huh oh interesting I'm talking to tie her to that
2000 fun I want you all to know that
I'm grateful to if I beside my friends
nice Warlock
is that Lila so cool
it is and how we found each other
cool it actually looks awesome ready one last ride
dude tracks man so worried about you dude I know I
don't want him to fly away together to the forever
and beautiful sky
I get the impression they're
looking for the high evolutionary
well there's that one scene with the
wait a second that whoever it was that
you were in love with it sounds more
like her hers do not bring me into them
knock it off how black your eyes were they were
replaced by my father as a method of torture he
he picked a pretty set oh God I was like are we
gonna change him Falling in Love by conversation
I ship them immediately I've seen I mean I've
been saying Karen's MVP of this franchise and
if that happens I'm in I really like the trailer
because what it demonstrated was more of the fun
side as comparative to the last trailer which
had some fun in there at the beginning but then
went full on emotional this had to good blend of
the array of the emotions that you would sort of
want from it or the melancholic side but also a
lot of the humerus side to it as well but what I
said in the middle of it about them looking for I
always was under the impression High evolutionary
came to them and from what it looks I mean
I'm not exactly sure why the impression that
I was getting was they're looking for him and it
sounds like it might have something to do with
rocket I've always thought that they were looking
for him well I think I mean it's very clear to me
that rocket is a creation of right yeah here too I
think that from the beginning they've been trying
to seek out what Rocket's Origins are in a way
like maybe they need to solve like maybe he's
hurt or maybe he's poison like there's something
like an impetus right yeah maybe he's the only one
that can save him because he built him yes so I'm
wondering with now tying that into it looked like
there was a shot where it cut to nebula like
immediately after saying like he only wants
to change things so now I'm curious if maybe he
was like one or a few new Thanos like I wonder if
there's going to be a tie into there was something
happening there with those creations and things
that'd be an interesting way to make the universe
a little tighter true true I mean it seems like
we got two plots here they're looking for high
evolutionary for some purpose that has something
to do with rock because I don't imagine that it's
high evolutionary it's like I want my rocket fast
raccoon it was the perfect day like it doesn't
seem like that's the case and they seem to be
showing a lot of imagery of Rocket like dying or
or being really sick yeah that's why I'm getting
poisoned so that's why I was thinking maybe they
need to go to to him to maybe help out rocket but
it's not going to go the way they would want it
to go yeah sure and and then they got the other
plot which is carrying over from Guardians 2 the
post-credits scene of man this keeps happening
to me what is the name of the gold people in
Guardians too uh Aisha Sovereign The Sovereign
thank you John uh The Sovereign warlock so you got
like this one plot where they're on the run and
they got this like beat this monstrosity coming
after them which is in the form of Adam Warlock
I don't know what's gonna come of that and I
still feel like Drax is going to be I think
Layla maybe tells them about the acceleration
area I thought it was Lila this whole time it
might be I've only read it yeah nobody read the
comic to me but like her uh maybe maybe she is
the you know inciting instant to get them on that
Journey because like you know we see them yes yes
bottom line it doesn't seem like oh bad guy showed
up it seems like they're looking for bad guy yeah
like resting across the cosmos and maybe like he's
pursuing them it'd be a cool like Chase Dynamic
like Adam warlock's pursuing them while they're
pursuing the high evolutionary that'll give you
a little bit more flavor of intensity and then
Adam Warlock takes out the high evolutionary well
and maybe there's like a yeah yeah second this
character shows up just murkham uh maybe there
will be like a parallel plot line though because
there's a lot in here about you know quill and
Gamora and their whole you know new report now
that she is back in a different iteration it's not
like before and then maybe you'll have like the
literal organic side of that with rocket trying
to reconnect with like the one person aside from
Groot who like really knows him or who he really
can you know feels some type of vulnerability with
yeah I'm wondering what will become of that with
Gamora because when I I don't feel like it would
go the direction that some of us might want where
this Gamora ends up falling in love with Peter
Quill I feel like it's gonna be a new set of what
is the crew that comes after one of the other
Crews it's like adjacent to the Guardians well
they they introduced another set of Guardians in
the ravagers at the end of Guardians yeah but I
don't think it'll be them I feel like it'll be a
new group but some of them from here will stick
for the future and I don't feel like the moral
part of that because I think this will be yeah
um no I I think that you know I I feel like
Drax is gonna today Batista just said too
much I feel like I feel like Jack's gonna die
and I think Chris Pratt too see that's what
I mean if Chris Pratt is going to die or he's
gonna leave guardians but he's gonna leave the
Guardians behind him like go on a separate
path because I don't feel like Gamora will
end up with them or maybe she will I mean let's
be the linear path and I don't think James Gunn
does linear or maybe we're thinking about
it because of that and he's double double
crossing because this has to be the at the ending
Trilogy note and that's why I think like this the
follow-up to Guardians I don't feel like the
Guardians will completely end I think there'll
be a different group of people that will still
have like rocket in there and Groot oh Seattle
I feel like Rock's gonna live and they're just
that's why they're showing us so much to get
us to think he's gonna die but I don't think
he's gonna actually die and I I wouldn't put
it past them to do that but at the same time yeah
I fee I keep getting the feeling that Drax will go
rocket will be the big emotional death and then
uh maybe somehow quill and Gamora will ride off
into the sunset and do their thing I don't think
you figure two if you got Drax who also died he'd
be like the Abrahams well then Walking Dead for
you guys like the Abraham to the to the Glenn
situation sure you'd be like everyone would just
think about like like rocket no one would really
think about it because he dies halfway through
the film my big question yeah they're like man
this is I'm so tired uh everyone's dying but I
I'm literally intrigued by Adam Warlock being
introduced softly in the first one in the Cocoon
right we've been building Adam Warlock so I'm
really intrigued by it now using the high
evolutionaries kind of a duality that Adam
Warlock if you've got the high evolutionary
duplicitous one might say uh no but I think I
think the interesting take on Adam Warlock is he
is the idea of perfection and then they just said
he isn't striving for Perfection he just wants to
change things so it'd be very interesting if they
have a commentary on like what Perfection is and
what evolution is versus what the evolutionary is
actually doing so you've got like the you know
the Nazis who experimented on people like like
the monsters they were being what happened you
know there's there's things that had intentions
but there's a reason we brought in some of their
scientists right guys we're all on the same time
being the Pure Evil and what that means for Adam
Warlock and how that relates like what it is to
achieve Perfection what it is to perceive their
being Perfection because if there's ever a team
that is human it's the Guardians even though if
they're not all human like so it's interesting
to have that duality of plot but has this time
to the DC Universe well you see James Gunn is
going to bring Chris Pratt over a Star-Lord and
then flash is going to reset the universe he's
gonna be at the end of the movie and then all the
cast is going to be pulled in got it okay now it
all makes sense yeah absolutely it's gonna be a
what if episode that is the amount of the universe
we're gonna get dark claw we're gonna get spider
boy we're gonna get all those characters they're
gonna split James Gunn is going to be the one
above all he's gonna have a mustache like Stanley
it's gonna be very confusing he who remains stand
gun oh I feel like this one it will Top at least
the second one Guardians one is the top of the top
of the list for like top five for Marvel for me
for sure same so I don't know exactly where this
will land this might be my favorite Trilogy though
when it's done I I I hope it does that effect for
me where okay yeah maybe I'm I'm not a big fan of
Guardians too but I would like to watch this one
and go but as a Trilogy it's a perfect package
yeah yeah I want that effect we're like going back
in hindsight it automatically elevates Guardians
too for me we'll see how it goes alrighty guys
well out of ten where'd you get the trailer uh
I mean I was immediately invested like 9.6 I was
enthralled sure I'll meet you at 9.6 koi 11. all
right eleven trailers Ahoy please today's the
day alrighty guys well thank you for being here
I can't wait to watch this movie and so yeah keep
looking for Ammon in the Lost quantumania coverage
coming up this week it's a similar tone I
suppose I feel like not before we do this
Mark Leach mark my dude it's Super Bowl Sunday
here and uh you're in the UK I don't think you
give a [__] about what's going on right now
nope so I figured you were the perfect person
to let feel welcome here well I'll let you know
as two Americans John right now is wishing he was
with his family watching the game and my family
could not care any damn about it I don't even
care about it never have never will I care more
about the Rihanna thing going on but I want to
say to you dude that I know 20 30 nope 23rd 2013
my years are off here um I know that uh 2022 was
a [__] year but I feel like this year you're
gonna really make it your own and I want you to
keep on doing that thing where you are able to be
vulnerable keep connecting and you have a gift of
empathy and you have a gift to really understand
people at a deeper level and also you are quite
you're just a very understanding individual
so please keep honing in on those qualities
and just amplify them even more because people
need that gift more and more the these days so
thank you so much for being you and I'm hoping
that uh it can be a more optimistic perspective
as you set forth on this journey ahead of you
buddy thank you again for being here [Music]